such a big fan of yours I'm just off the
top I'm so curious because Jenny and
Georgia is such a popular show on
Netflix right now when you're a song
America's sweetheart played in season
one that's how I discovered you do you
get a lot of fans from that show
um
I don't know I'm not gonna lie I've been
really bad at socials ever since I had
my kid and um I but my mom was very
excited because she watched the show so
um I'm grateful because that that
definitely helped great like bring back
and bring a Resurgence to what is
technically an older song so yeah I was
really happy about it okay so let's go
right into the adorableness that is your
son lucky you posted a video recently of
him celebrating his birthday and eating
cake yeah I pushed his face into it and
I said I wasn't gonna do it
but that's what Parenthood is you do
things that you swear you'll never do
how did he react after that video ended
um he was fine he was good he had a good
birthday it was it was beautiful so yeah
he's so sweet I love him I love that
what has lucky brought to your life that
you didn't quite expect
laughs
I didn't expect to ever have that like
I've always had a very strong work ethic
um but I didn't expect that I would
become such an organized person oh I've
always had like very create like OCD
stuff but the organization that I need I
just really wanted to give my son
structure and so through that it's it's
brought structure to My Life
um which is a good thing I'll take it
that's a good quality to have it's new
to me but um I definitely enjoy it I
don't know if my partner would
um he would he would say that I am too
structured that I need to loosen up a
bit but yeah I didn't ever think that I
would be a strict parent but I don't
know yeah I love that honestly kids do
things right you don't expect you're
gonna react as a mom and there you go I
love hearing that okay so let's talk
about your new music come get your wife
such a good title for your album what
did you want to say with this collection
of music
first and foremost I really wanted to
say thank you
um and I've been given this kind of new
breath into creativity and and like
expressive Freedom
um and you know ever since I first
experience modern country music
um everyone that I met reminded me of my
family and my childhood and I felt this
like
it's like Comfort
um and so through that I could let my
walls down and the people that I worked
with let me just be myself and everybody
honored my ideas or helped me like
fine-tune certain things and and I got a
lot of peace and
um I I think having all this like
beautiful support and the community in
Nashville
um I just felt so comfortable and I I
thought I always had to make music from
an uncomfortable place and I thought
that that's what drove me I didn't
realize that I could create powerful and
and awesome badass music through places
of Joy that's a new experience for me
because I I can only speak on my own
personal experience but music was always
a cathartic outlet for me to create
through pain or awkwardness or something
and I never knew that I could
have such a like even more I used to
always chase that like that feeling that
like buzzing feeling that you would get
in the studio when when you're creating
and I didn't know that I could get an
even bigger one creating from a place of
joy and happiness and
um
I don't know I still don't understand it
but I like it and
um Nashville and country music has has
changed my life and
um I love living here and also you know
I just wanted to say thank you to anyone
who's given me a chance in country
um I never understood
like how or why people would want to
cross over into country until I
understood why people wanted to cross
over in the country and it's because
it's just the best feeling and it's it's
I don't know it's incredible so I just
wanted to share what
country has done for my life and and
share what country is to me and yeah
that's what people can I guess hear from
my album
I love that you do seem like you're
having a lot of fun with this music and
your music videos we have to talk about
try Jesus like I love the song but I was
laughing out loud watching this music
video so the question of the day is what
was more intense all the milk or the
beans
the milk was disgusting
um and but nobody told me to pour milk
on myself by the way I knew that was you
yeah the milk was gross but the the
beans were that was a real experience
a fly landed on my eyeball and
um like they and there was no shower
that was a real dollar store and so I
had some like kind of like a slop sink
or whatever and um they would just like
kind of try and put the top half of my
body but we were running out of time so
I had like beans in my bra
um when I was doing all the other
characters and everything so the beads
were just testing yeah but worth it but
so worth it honestly I just kept
laughing and laughing and it just the
lyrics are so empowering as well so it's
just it kind of hits all the emotions
which I loved um you have amazing
collaborations on this album Dierks
Bentley obviously Miranda Lambert I just
love you two together you have like such
a special
um I don't know what it is like I can
feel it how do you describe that
ah
I don't know Miranda is he's such
like she is truly a superstar and yeah
she cares so much I learned so much from
touring with her and just from being
around her she cares so much about her
show and her fans and
um
she wanted to have an all-female lead
tour
um and it and to promote that fool
around Found Love was a song that
everybody was going to be a part of the
tourist sang on it was all her idea and
you know talk about like literally like
pulling someone into the spotlight and
sharing the stage every night we would
go up on stage and we would all sing it
together and um I had nothing on country
radio I I didn't live in Nashville I had
nothing going I was on I was coming off
of a massive Rock Tour on tour with
heart and Joan Jett and Miranda just
wanted to put on a good show and um I
was going through just you know
heartbreak in my life and
um she was a friend to me and but the
kind of friend the kind of friend you
want when you're going through a breakup
which is you don't have to talk about it
let's drink about it and he just gave me
this this real freedom of like don't
worry about it don't worry about it like
you're good you're good get as drunk as
you want and it was just fun and we
became friends and
um through that we were coming back to
Nashville every week because Country
Superstars know how to tour which is the
weekend and then you come back and you
have three days of a life it's what it's
a wild notion
um and so I was coming back and I
rewrote I rewrote the the lyrics to
Drunk which was the song that I wrote
the day after American sweetheart almost
10 years ago so it was just this I don't
know this wild kind of
Perfect Storm of time and I never knew
that it was supposed to be a duet and
I'm honored that she's sang on it with
me her singing that song um you know
Dirk's bringing me into country and
asking me to sing on different for girls
changed my life Dirk's introduced me to
Miranda which changed my life and
um I kind of just never I haven't looked
back ever since